It's a small body.
It should have cooled off long ago.
Nothing very interesting is going on.
And when we actually got out to Ceres,
nothing could have been further from the
truth.
March 2015, NASA's dawn probe arrives at
Ceres.
As the Dawn spacecraft pulled up to Ceres, we
saw the craters and the surface that we
expected to see.
And then all of a sudden, something totally
mysterious rotated into view.
One of the craters had two bright spots,
almost like two eyes staring right back at
us.
It was such a puzzle to the science
community, because what are these doing here?
Are they ice? It looks very fresh.
What on earth could it be?
Scientists find over 100 of these mysterious
white spots.
The largest is in a 50 mile wide crater
called Occator.
They are unexpectedly made up of a substance
we find on Earth.
Sodium carbonate, a kind of salt.
We believe the salts on Ceres are actually
very young.
We think they're as young as 4 million years
old.
And that's basically like yesterday in terms
of geology.
And that is super weird, right?
That's happening not on sort of a geologic
era.
It's happening now today.
What could cause patches of salt on a world
long presumed dead?
Planetary geologist Jenny Rathbun believes a
clue might be found at Mono Lake in
California.
All right, I'm here looking at this beautiful
lake off in the distance and standing on
massive white deposits.
These white deposits used to be a part of
this lake.
At one point, the lake had dissolved a lot
of the materials in it.
And then as it receded, it left behind the
materials as it evaporated away.
And these things are salts.
They're kind of granular in texture.
And just to make sure we taste it and yeah,
sure enough, it's salty.
The salt at lake mono crystallizes as the
water evaporates, the only way it can form.
The researchers believe the same process is
taking place on series.
This means there must be liquid water
beneath the surface.
But how? Out in the deep freeze of the
asteroid belt.
These bright spots are located in the centers
of craters.
They're located around cracks in the
surface.
And that is telling us that this material is
coming from under the surface and welling up
onto it.
Absolutely nobody expected there to be liquid
water beneath the surface of Ceres.
We cannot explain what is keeping that water
warm.
On some moons, gravitational tugging keeps
the interiors warm.
But series is not really near anything else
that's very large.
So the amazing thing is that we may not even
understand how rocky planets work.
There may be another source of energy,
another mechanism for heating the interior
that we haven't even discovered yet.
To find out how serious has liquid water.
We have to rewind the clock 4.6 billion
years.
Debris left over from the formation of the
sun slams together to form the dwarf planets.
As they take shape, the heavier rocky
material sinks to the center and forms a hot
molten core.
Slushy water ice floats to the top.
For a while it stays liquid, but once the
core cools, it freezes and forms the solid
mantle and crust.
That surface should still be solid, so the
salt patches remain a perplexing mystery.
We still haven't answered the question How
could there actually still be liquid water on
Ceres? That's still a hard question to
answer.
One way this could happen is if it's not
actually pure water, if you've mixed it with
something else.
Some scientists have proposed that a salty
ocean lies beneath the surface.
The high concentration of salt lowers the
freezing point of the water, keeping it
liquid. When asteroid
impacts fracture the crust, this salty water
oozes up from below.
The liquid swiftly evaporates, but the salt
remains, leaving a brilliant white spot on
the surface.
In fact, I'm willing to bet there could be
water coming up now, bringing salts up to the
surface, evaporating way into space.
And that means liquid water is very close to
the surface of Ceres right now.
Series has an even more startling card up its
sleeve.
Recent research suggests that it's an
immigrant.
It didn't form anywhere near the asteroid
belt.
Ceres may have been born alongside hundreds
of other dwarf planets, many billions of
miles away from the sun.
So how did it get here?
Most of the dwarf planets we've discovered
live far out in the solar system beyond the
orbit of Neptune.
But series orbits between Mars and Jupiter
in the asteroid belt.
But its location isn't the only hint.
Ceres might be an interloper.
Normally celestial objects are made of the
same materials as the other bodies in their
neighborhoods. But that's not the case with
Ceres.
The asteroid belt is mostly made up of dry,
rocky bodies composed of the same heavy
elements that form the rocky inner planets.
Series is very different.
Series is essentially an icy world, right?
It's it's made out of ices instead of rocks.
And so that's kind of weird, considering
where it is.
The ice on Ceres also contains chemical
compounds that in the early years of the
solar system didn't exist in the asteroid
belt.
The more we learned about series, the more
mysterious it became.
One of the things is that series has quite a
lot of ammonia on it, and we don't find
ammonia anywhere near the inner part of the
solar system.
But we do find it in the outer solar system.
We've detected ammonia on Pluto.
It's Moon Charon and out in the frozen
Kuiper Belt where we find the other dwarf
planets.
We think that the origin of that ammonia
would have had to be in a very cold part of
the solar system colder than where we find
Ceres today.
But how an icy dwarf planet with ammonia came
to inhabit a place where ammonia can't form.
That's a huge puzzle.
This suggests to us that Ceres perhaps formed
in the outer solar system and then migrated
inwards to its present location in the
asteroid belt.
We used to think that planetary orbits were
completely immutable, that they were simply
ran like clockwork and they didn't move
around.
Now we know that that's not the case in the
early stages of planet formation.
Planets move around through the gaseous disk
that encircles the young sun, much like rafts
that are pushed around by ocean currents.
Is ammonia suggests that dwarf planets rafted
around on the cosmic ocean, along with the
Young Planets.
Series is sort of a smoking gun that solar
systems are much more dynamic, much more
dramatic than we know.
There's mounting evidence that Ceres formed
farther out in the solar system and something
brought this little world in.
What could possibly have done that?